rick likes to exaggerate about the  length of the fish that he catches if  rick added four inches to the amount of  fish he had said it would be three times  the actual amount if rick added two  inches to the actual amount it would be  half of what he said how long was the  fish  to solve this problem let y be the  amount he said and x be the actual  amount  if rick added four inches to the amount  of fish he had said that would be y plus  four  this is equal to three times the actual  amount which is three x  if rick added 2 inches to the actual  amount that would be 2 plus x and that  would be half of what he said  that is equal to y over 2.  so we want to solve the system of  equations for x  one way to do that is to multiply the  second equation by two so that four plus  two x is equal to y  then substitute this value of y into the  first equation  so four plus four plus two x is equal to  three x subtract two x from both sides  so that x is equal to 8 inches and  that's the answer